bonjour je m'appelle William CV j'ai 23
ans j'ai 25 pôles je le permis le
véhicule je recherche un emploi de
serveuse dans la zone de l'Ouest j'ai
déjà effectué des stages dans ce domaine
ça m'a plus beaucoup et c'est pour cela
que j'aimerais faire mon métier en tant
que serveur d'un restauration comme
formation j'ai fait une remise à niveau
pour apprendre pour apprendre de maths
français pour être à l'aise avec des
gens et comme diplôme j'ai obtenu le CFG
au CFG certificat de formation générale
je suis sportive j'aime pas être
football mes qualités je suis souriante
patiente sérieux j'aime travailler en
équipe et je suis accueillante je suis
prête dès demain à travailler n'hésitez
pas à m'appeler